hey what's up guys my name is a Jonah
and welcome to episode 103 of game
programming I know it's been a while
since the last episode but here we are
hopefully there's going to be a little
bit more frequent from here on out but
basically what we're going to do today
is take a look at how mobs are going to
be able to shoot at other mobs okay so
instead of um because really they have
absolutely no form form of attack right
now and I thought it would be good to
kind of give them one just because um
well it's probably desirable and so what
we basically going to be able to do here
is make a brand new mob that has the
ability to shoot at the player okay it's
not going to have any kind of AI okay
it's only just going to be able to find
the player and shoot them it's I'm going
to walk towards the players it's going
to be a stationary mob that will shoot
at the player whenever just whenever
okay so let's let's just take a look at
that and see what we can do so over here
under our mob folder inside our mob
package of course we'll create a new
class we will call it so that basically
this is just good this is just going to
be a brand new mob that has the ability
to shoot so I'll call this shooter okay
really creative we'll make sure that of
course it does inherit the mom plus
since it is a mob we'll add the elements
and methods here which have to be update
and render of course and and what we're
basically going to do is copy more or
less well we don't even need a copy
anything kay we could make the mob move
and we might do a bit of that in a
minute but we don't really have to
because that's not the goal of it so
really what we want to be able to make
it do is shoot but first thing we should
do is just basically render it so let's
go ahead and go screen to render mob at
of course X you know why and demobbing
this thing okay and the thing is though
the thing that people don't realize is
that this is actually how easy it is to
make a new mob okay one thing we should
do is set X&Y okay in the constructor so
we might make a new constructor here
called public shooter will set in
accident Y into the
into the construct into the parameters
with constructor here and will of course
just assign this dot X equal to X and
start wife to Y but we might just
multiply that by 32 16 or 16 so Stiles I
think we are in a long time or just
multiply it by or shift it left sorry by
4 that'll be the same as multiplying by
16 great that's actually what we did I
think in pretty much every other mob so
da me hand that as well as you can see
we should also set the sprite so we'll
set the sprite to be dummy okay now
gonna do anything fancy it's just going
to look at the same as a dummy's right
that's it
now what is going to do those shoe so
this is actually you see this code here
there's like no code here almost at all
but all this code that's all you need to
create brand new mob okay and in update
is where you can call methods like move
like shoot which is what we're going to
do in a minute
and control the behavior of your mom
again in the render you can control any
visual aspects so visual and logic okay
and then this is like initialization
code so where we want to put the shooter
on what sprite we want to give it all
that stuff so now let's go ahead and
actually add it into the level of course
we provided a mob type we've created the
class we've created the kind of template
for it the template but what we want to
do now is add it into the level so the
our current level is our spawn level
right that's the actual level that we
walk around in we've added chase them
all as we've added star mobs let's just
get rid of stubble comment out star and
chaser and dummy okay honestly like
we're dealing with it I'm I've got I
mean I mean I'm convinced that you guys
consider these mobs all work so there's
no need having a million mobs for nine
million but seven in this in this case
running around and distracting us from
from what we want to test out so I'll
just come them out what so we'll add a
new shooter and we'll just pop it in I
think da me like 2255 that was a pretty
good location okay and let's import
shooter okay so now we've added in to
enter the level we've got a one shooter
of course into the level and here and
I'm our shooter class you can see that's
all it is so if we just launched this
really quickly you'll see that what we
should get is right over here we have
just one more and it's just do nothing
right it can't do anything because
there's nothing in the update method if
we were to put something along the lines
of let's just say move up
so moves 0-1 here just into the update
method then it will just move up and
it's all we do you can see that doesn't
even have any animation nothing it's
just her mob okay so yeah I mean I'm
pretty sure you guys already knew that
but just in case you didn't that's how
all that works so into the update method
now let's just make it shoot at the
player kind of like a turret because
it's not moving around so we'll make it
kind of like a turret at this point so
what do we need to shoot at the player
okay I actually saw a comment or a forum
post on my website the other day and by
the other day I mean like a month
probably about two months ago that said
that it would be very very hard to
implement this kind of stuff because I
think someone else on the forum asked
how one would do this and the other guy
was like it's really hard it's really
not okay it's honestly that the whole
thing is going to take us three lines of
code and you could actually probably
condense it into one line of code but
some basically we need to get the player
because we want to shoot at the player
so we need to get the player we need to
somehow be able to get the player's
position since we want to shoot at the
player so let's go ahead and get the
player from the level because we have a
wonderful method in level and in our
level class called get client player and
what that will do is just get the local
player because obviously this is going
to be multiplied game and this get
client player will just get the first
okay the very first player in the
players array list because the very
first player plays it players are really
a rail list is the player that well
guess we're playing locally okay so it's
not some multiplayer plates player we're
controlling great okay so once we've
done that we are somehow calculate a
direction okay because what this will
what what this P variable that we've
created which is an object of course of
the player class we've set it equal to
get the client player okay from the
level which is just getting I guess the
player that we're controlling not some
other you know multi player player and
then what we want to do now is figure
out the direction that we want to shoot
with that we want to get our shooter mob
to shoot in okay because if we just
bring up paint.net here
I've actually already drawn a diagram
look at that um I was rehearsing this
episode because that's just how good I
am okay so what we've got here is
basically how we're going to work it out
so we can use the atan2 method here to
actually get I guess the angle okay in
radians because what we what we know
let's just say that we are this mob over
here right all rather less because it's
red let's make let's just make it that
is us I was going to make it the enemy
but doesn't matter that's us and then
this here is the enemy or no rather red
is the enemy blue is us okay and what we
want to do is we want to shoot we're
going to get the enemy to shoot towards
us right so basically we want the
bullets here are the projectiles to
follow give me good color to follow this
kind of line yeah this black line here
so to work that out we need two things
we need a bunch of things okay and first
thing is are the X and will basically
all we need actually to be honest is the
x and y coordinates or the I guess the
position of both of these mobs okay the
players also want by the way it just
happens to be controlled by us right
okay we just we just need that
information okay
then once we get that we can work out DX
okay Delta X so what that is is it's
basically just X minus X doesn't matter
which one because we're going to well I
get yeah it doesn't really matter which
one comes first I don't think if you
really want to be good though you're
probably a bsut so absolute it so that
is always positive because you want a
positive result here that's the idea so
we basically just go ahead and say X
minus X and that is what DX equals right
and then dy is just going to be dy
equals y minus y okay and by Y minus y I
mean this Y minus this way okay so
that's what we want to do then what we
get is two variables DX and dy and then
once we've got those two we just
basically feed them in into this method
and it will do some pretty fancy stuff
basically work out the inverse of tan
okay and then that will give us of
course an angle which we can then
use to figure out the I guess the angle
or the direction of the projectile that
we want to fly towards okay so that's
how that that's the math behind it okay
so I'm going to stretch this out over a
little several lines of code just
because uh probably be easy for you guys
this way so I think positions in our
sword was doubled so um go ahead and say
px which is going to be the players x
position that's obviously just going to
be flat player dog get X or Peter get X
P Y is going to be player get Y prettier
obvious X is just going to be get X Y is
just going to be get line that's just
going to get our Y in fat I'm pretty
sure when we need that we killed I think
we've got access to it anyway yet we do
okay and then that's it okay that's all
we need to work out our direction here
okay so our direction then is going to
equal as we kind of spelled out here ah
math dot math dot a 10-2 and then we
just simply feed in I guess definitely Y
let's work out DX and dy separately so
DX is just going to be px minus X okay
and dy is just going to be P Y minus y
all right that's it
so this of course you could just
substitute this for and you wouldn't
need this variable at all and you would
get rid of two lines of code here
because you do it for x and y so what I
mean is you could just do this and then
you wouldn't need that but again y'alls
do that I'm pretty sure you guys can
tell what is what here and this is
getting one yeah there you go
okay so we've got the x and dy now we
simply go make sure you do dy first by
the way otherwise you'll get ridiculous
results right that's it okay we now know
our direction of fires now what we have
to do is actually shoot the projectile
luckily for us that's very easy to do
because we made a shoot method in the
mob class it's right over here
and all that does is it simply shoot the
projectile with the given angle and it
adds it up into the level of course
let's get rid of this commented code as
well we don't need it okay wonderful
so now let's shoot it of course
at our exposition that's kind of where
we want the projectile to start from
just our X&Y because we want to be able
to hear it I guess the shoot-'em-up
needs to be able to treat it from itself
XY and then the direction that's it okay
this is in the update method so just
going to constantly do that sixty times
a second okay there's no flight
restriction nothing okay so let's go
ahead and and try that out you can see
there's a lot of fly to us right now
okay and as I move look at that now it's
it's and as you can see by the way like
the collision for that is just perfect
as well
so everything is working as if it was us
firing around projectile like that okay
now one thing you probably notice is
that um the the start of this is uh not
in the center and that's that's not our
problem that's not an actual problem
that's just the fact that there's no
rendering offset so what you probably
want to do and not just rendering offset
but what you probably want to do is um
one or two things so you'll note the
dummy
does not have any kind of offset at all
okay whereas all the other mobs that
we've made such as the star mob for
example actually has an offset of
negative 16 okay so what you could do is
offset that render rendering things so
that it actually gets rounded kind of
from the center rather than from the
top-left corner or what you could do if
you don't want to do that so that's one
that's one way right just minus sixteen
for both x and y or you could add
sixteen to this and it will give you the
same result I'll show you but some yeah
I had to you what you prefer to do so
you can see that's all right that's
originated from the center here and if I
do the same for get rid of that and just
call minus sixteen twice here you can
see that we get the same result okay
it's originating in what is roughly the
center again you can tweak that however
you'd like okay wonderful so what about
if he wants to move well we've kind of
covered that before
so in dami let's just make a move
randomly right so I'm just going to copy
this entire logic here and paste it into
here okay and then there's a bunch of
stuff here that we should change so for
example ah we need a variable here
called time so private int time
equals zero we also need two messages XA
equals zero and y equals zero all right
and I think that's I'm going to animate
it sprite as well so we need all this
stuff
and we'll just pop that up here and we
should be set just get rid of that okay
so let's just try that now what our mobs
should be able to do is walk randomly
and you can see he's just completely
firing at us and there's actually no
animation because we never rendered this
sprite so I think we just need this one
line of code here from dummy to shooter
and we should be animated and walking
properly there you see so he's just
constantly firing at us and you can see
he's always firing exactly at us look at
that he's moving why not he's firing
exactly at us eventually it'll get our
range or something but yeah okay see so
that is how simple it is it's literally
like a few lines of code a couple lines
of code here just this that's it that's
everything to make him shoot so do with
that what you will next episode though
what we're going to do is talk about
multiple targeting so we're kind of
going to cover targeting so what if we
don't just want every single mob in the
game or the shooter mob to shoot at the
player what if we want that mob to shoot
at whoever's closest or at at a random
mob within a range right and as you can
see this guy's just shooting at us
constantly no matter where we are so if
we're here he can't reach us but he's
still shooting us there's no like a
range or anything of course there is a
range to the projectiles that's why
they're kind of be spawning here but
this he'll even shooter those through
walls and everything but um yeah so
we're going to talk about multiple
targeting and how we can deal with that
in the next episode but I hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of game programming
if you want to support this series and
make sure that I basically I guess have
the time to make more of these episodes
in other words if you guys enjoy the
series and you want to help out I do
have a patron a patreon page it's just
patreon lock on for slash the Cherno
here as you can see and go into that
basically you can just become a patron
by pledging a certain amount of money
like a dollar or you know $0.50 whatever
that is per video and then what you'll
be able to do is just basically every
time I release one of the
these videos I guess you'll get you
basically just get charged and then I
will get that money thus giving me more
time to make more videos very very
simple the other thing I want to
obviously mention here is that I do over
forums so in other words if you guys
have some problems with your game or
something's going on or you you want to
collaborate with someone here you want
to showcase some of your work whatever
you want off-topic talk about your cat
your bunny I don't know you can do that
the game programming subreddit of course
subretinal subreddit sub-forum I guess
the game programming form refers to this
series you can see it's really active I
mean today is the first of March and
there's already been two posts in just
this forum so and I've haven't even made
a video and like a month so this is
really this really um active which is
good and you can see that all of these
things basically have replies okay out
of this added like the tons that I'm
just playing here only two don't have
any replies okay and it's only been like
a couple days in like three days
so not only three days two days so um
that is that's that okay make sure you
go to that make sure you register here
you can register it's free of course and
and that's it okay I'll see you guys in
the next episode which will be multiple
targeting goodbye